cuánto es 19 millares más siete decenas
primero veamos qué significan 19
millares y siete decenas y después
veremos cómo sumar las 19 millares es la
suma de mil 19 veces tenemos aquí mil
más mil
si sumamos dos veces 1000 tendremos 2000
si sumamos 1000 tres veces tendremos
tres mil mil dos mil tres mil y este
patrón debe ser bastante claro si
tenemos 19 veces 1000 tendremos 19.000 ó
19 millares así que 19 millares son 19
veces mil y 19 mil y hacemos lo mismo
para las siete decenas tenemos siete
veces diez diez más otro diez más otro
este es un poco más sencillo de hacer
que el de diecinueve ya que aquí sólo
tenemos que contar siete veces diez
aquí tenemos seis diez es y 7 10 es así
que siete decenas es siete veces 10 o 70
10 20 30 40 50 60 y 70 así que siete
decenas es 70 y si queremos combinar o
sumar estas cantidades tendrá
19 mil 0 centenas las siete decenas y 0
unidades o 19 mil 70 pudimos pensar esto
también en términos del valor posicional
en lugar de escribir todos los millares
o escribir todas las escenas tenemos 19
millares lo que quiere decir que nuestro
último dígito va a estar en la posición
de los millares y nuestro otro dígito el
1 va antes que el 9 por lo que leemos
esto como 19 millares y al escribir aquí
millares cubrimos estos lugares vacíos o
los tres ceros que terminaremos
añadiendo los millares pueden
representarse con estos tres ceros al
final mientras que las siete decenas la
ponemos en el lugar de las decenas y
tenemos un lugar vacío en las unidades
al decir decenas dejamos implícito este
cero al final así que los millares
implican estos tres ceros al final y las
decenas implican este cero al final
de nuevo si los combinamos vamos a tener
el resultado que vimos anteriormente
19.000 0 centenas 7 decenas y 0 unidades
así que de cualquier forma sin importar
si especificamos la cantidad de 19.000
literalmente y lo combinamos con 7
decenas o literalmente 7 veces 10 o si
vemos la posición de valor y ponemos los
ceros al final de cualquiera de estas
dos formas nuestra solución será 19 1070
aquí tenemos otro problema 5 decenas de
millar más 22 millares nuevamente
tenemos dos formas de pensar en cómo
resolver esto una es pensar en cuánto es
cinco decenas de millar si tenemos una
decena de millar cinco veces o diez mil
más otro diez mil más otro diez mil
más otros 10.000
más otro 10.000 nos dará un total de 50
mil 10.000 20.000 30.000 40.000 50.000
así que cinco decenas de millar son
50.000 lo escribimos aquí 50 mil más 22
millares recuerden cuando hicimos los 19
millares escribimos un millar serían
1000 si escribimos mil dos veces serán
dos mil o dos millares si lo escribimos
22 veces tendremos 22 mil y podemos
combinar estos números 50 mil más 22 mil
nos dará un total de 72 mil así que la
primera forma es pensar en cuánto es
este número cuánto es 5 decenas de
millares y cuánto es 22 millares así
obtenemos nuestras cantidades y después
las sumamos y la otra forma en la que
podemos resolver esto es usando nuestra
tabla de valor posicional
aquí tenemos nuestra tabla y escribimos
nuestra primera cantidad
5 decenas de millar así que ponemos
nuestros cinco en la posición de las
decenas de millar cinco decenas de
millar y escribimos cero en las
posiciones que quedaron vacías ya que no
tenemos ni millares ni centenas ni
decenas ni unidades así que para decenas
de millares tendremos cuatro ceros al
final nuestra otra cantidad es 22
millares así que el último dígito lo
escribimos en la posición de los
millares
aquí tenemos 22 millares recuerden que
siempre ponemos el último dígito
diferente de 0 en la posición que le
corresponde así que tenemos 22 millares
y con los millares agregamos 3 ceros al
final finalmente cuando combinamos ambas
cantidades tenemos 7 en la posición de
las decenas de millar tenemos dos
millares y ninguna centena ni decena ni
unidad así que nuestra solución de 5
decenas de millares más 22 millares es
72 millares o 72.000